a lunged in the hammer bulbs last for the right machine. What's a hammer bulb?
Well, so the hammer bulbs are the lung tubular bulbs. They were called hammer
bulbs because you could hit them with a hammer and they would break.
Well, that's the plexiglass outside you could hit with a hammer.
Maybe they had a different name for a hammer bulb. Maybe it was invented by
Mr. Hammer. I don't know. But I always said they're fairly unbreakable.
If you hit the plexiglass, the plexiglass, you could crack.
Of course, if you hit it hard, but you the glass inside is encased in the plexiglass.
And the glass inside is the bulb. And inside the bulb is a gas.
And the gas is what lights up when certain frequencies are transmitted through that gas.
And that is what is treating you as the frequencies through that light.
So, can you break them? Well, if you hit it hard enough with a hammer,
you probably break the plexiglass and you could break the glass.
I haven't had anybody yet. In all the years doing this, break the glass.
But I have had it happens all the time where the wires burn out or the wires get pulled out.
Or somebody trips on the wires and it gets damaged at where it plugs into the right machine.
Or, you know, you drop the bulb and it hits right at the wrong way and it damages the connection
of where the wire is connected to the bulb.
If you damage the connection where the wire is connected to the glass bulb inside itself,
most of you can't see the damage unless you took it all apart.
You can't see the damage. And the gas will leak out.
So, if you damage the wire as it's soldered to the glass itself,
it's welded, I think, with a glass weld.
So, you can't repair that. And if it was damaged, the gas would leak out.
And unless you are a bulb manufacturer that is using the specific gases that are in the bulb,
you can't fix it. It's not repairable. So, if that's the case, I mean, the bulb manufacturer
will repair it either. It's just a possible item. So, unfortunately, that isn't fixable.
We've had several, that has happened dozens and dozens of times where people drop it or drops
out of bed and it falls just wrong and it just breaks that and the gas leaks out.
And it looks perfectly normal. You can't even see sometimes if you take it apart.
But it's just not working.
Other ways that the bulbs burn out is the wires. That's the most common way that they burn out
because you are running high frequencies through this and it can just literally fry the wires.
And those can be soldered together. I can't, I don't do that and the manufacturer does not do that.
Understand the price of the bulbs. We don't make a penny off the bulbs. So,
we can't guarantee the bulbs. So, if you get them at their working and then something happens,
they stop working. There's no, we don't have any guarantee of the bulbs. So, we just can't,
we don't get anybody back and we're a small clinic. We can't, we just can't do it. So, be careful
with it. No, just in the last year or so and closed. So, most of these people that are on this
little call right now wouldn't have seen this in the last year. So, we even closed a sheet of
paper with the right that says this is delicate equipment. And, you know, most of the time I,
let's be honest. I was the first clinician ever to start sending people home with rife machines.
These are initially used to use in clinics. So, you have to treat them like a delicate piece of
equipment. You have to be really careful with them. And I know most people are, but, you know,
if you have kids and dogs and, you know, animals and grandkids and things can get jostled and
things can break. So, you don't have to be careful with them. So, yes, the bulbs can break. How long do
they last? Depends on how care that goes in, even if it took really good care. If you're ready to
high frequencies with cancer frequencies through these bulbs, you can burn out the wire and it's no
fault of yours. It just, it just is what it is. So, they can, you know, they can burn out in six
months. They can burn out in three months. They can burn out in, you know, I have personally a bulb
that we use in the clinic that's probably 10 years old and it has never burned out. Of course,
that's really not a true rife. So, it's a much lower frequencies. Other tell you about it,
you're going to have more chance of bulbs burning out because you're ready to hire frequencies.
That's what you really want. So, it's the price you pay for getting better.